I have a progression of disease in my liver a couple of weeks ago. I did a castorile pack
and the next day I had a lot of pain. I have not done one since. I have not had pain since.
You think the castorile caused the pain? Would this be a good pain or a bad pain? You think I should
try to get it and see what happens. So what is castor oil going to pack over the liver going to do?
It's going to help flow. So it's going to help with liver flow. But if there's blockage because
space-occupatory lesions, a cancer in the liver, that might not be a good thing. However,
it could have been a good thing because maybe the pain was from the stench and you had more flow
through a duct into the gallbladder. So maybe it was a detox reaction that you were getting
more pain from that. Now, okay, I'm not an alternative doctor that's going to say everything,
oh, you're not a castorile pack, then you had paid. That was a good pain. That was a detox reaction.
You need to do it again. Okay, that's just physiological nonsense by a biased practitioner
for an alternative practitioner. We have to assess everything. Is this a good thing or is it a bad thing?
Not because some alternative book I read or because of my education says it was that was a good
pain. It certainly could have caused more issues. I'd be careful. So when you don't know if it was a
good pain or a bad pain, you could look at objective data. And so let me give you an example.
Was this a good pain of flushing maybe delivered? It was a good thing that that happened.
And because of the flushing caused a distinction of the bile of the duct and that caused the pain.
But it actually ended to be a good thing because I flushed a lot of stuff out of the liver.
And it actually helped my cancer. Or was it a bad thing because it caused more inflammation in the
liver and my liver couldn't handle it. And if I did it again, it would do it again. That's not a good
thing. Well, how do I know that? Well, objective data. Do we have, you know, before and after CT scan?
No, do we have, you know, before and after ultrasound? Is there any way to do it? Well, we could do
something like before and after blood test is by, you know, with liver cancer to be weird,
have an elevated alkaline phosphatase, elevated AST, elevated ALT, did it get worse after that?
So I've had people that that that could happen. So the cancer opact was a bad thing. It caused more
inflammation in the liver. Because there's blockage, it couldn't get out. So that inflammation
caused distinction in the liver and that's what caused the pain. So doing a cancer opact would be a
bad thing. But also, if that was the case, you probably would have seen an elevation of those
liverbarkers and elevation of the alkaline phosphatase, elevation of AST, elevation of
ALT. Well, I don't know. I didn't have blood work. Well, you're getting, I think you're getting
blood work on a fairly regular basis. If you could look at it objectively. So if my ALT
AST and alkaline phosphatase went down after that episode, I'd say it would be a good thing. Maybe
I want to do it again. Maybe I want to do it for a short period of time. I don't want to hurt so bad.
But if you don't have any of that data, I don't know. I don't know. I don't have any of that data.
Then you could test it. You could say, well, I'm hoping it was a good thing. Maybe I did the
Castural Pack from 15 minutes last time. Maybe I'll only do it for two minutes this time.
Oh, I did it for two minutes. Didn't have any pain. Maybe I'll do it for two minutes again tomorrow.
Things like that. So you might have to test that. So if you don't have objective data giving you
information, whether that was a good thing or a bad thing, then you might want to test it. I would
also, you know, just on that point again, I want to kind of pound down that you see a lot of stuff
on Instagram and Facebook that, you know, every person should do this. Even the question before
about cancer is a metabolic disease. Well, of course, cancer is a metabolic disease. There's
nothing new there. Does that doesn't mean that everybody with cancer should do a ketogenic diet?
Well, they should change their diet. They should do different things in their diet.
And it doesn't mean that okay, the same thing you could say with coffee animals. I didn't
coffee animals and it actually caused more pain. Well, it could have been a good thing.
It could have been a bad thing. We don't know. We got to test things just because
ex-Gerson said everybody should do coffee animals. Doesn't mean it's right for you. So same thing with
castorile packs, same thing with ketogenic diet, same thing with everything. Everybody's unique.
So and everybody's physiology can be affected in different ways because of things going on.
So there isn't one approach to everybody. So if you can test it objectively,
that's the best way to go. Can't really do that. You can test it subjectively by
try it in a little bit. Maybe do it in a short period of time. That's what my suggestion would be.